a god is almost always gonna finish I
don't think a girl is always gonna
finish like - that is the most accurate
statement
I don't put into thought like as I'm
getting into sick I'm ready for this to
last 8 minutes and 45 seconds duration
can be really important but it's not the
end-all be-all satisfaction at the end
I'll be off
I don't think is as important as quality
to me it's not very important if it's
like short or really long I think it's
like if you're attentive to my needs
I'll be attentive to yours and your
pleasures and all that stuff it sounds
so weird I don't think that's right now
mom I'm sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
so I said I think to shorts probably two
minutes wait five minutes like 30
seconds maybe I said five seconds I said
a minute and 35 30 seconds but if you do
come in 30 seconds see open with your
partner figure out other things that you
enjoy under 4 minutes you know is like
adequate is like 3 minutes I'll just
double that adequate 3 to 10 minutes cuz
that doesn't include foreplay I put like
10 minutes at acquit I'd say is about 25
20 minutes maybe I said like 10 minutes
for the to long it would be an hour
definitely more than 90 minutes too long
I think anything them but pure
penetration like after 6 minutes it's
like all right like an hour but saint
averages maybe eight i think it's five
minutes probably two to three minutes is
pi the average I think the average time
is 11 minutes average 26 seconds you
have to think of how many young people
are having sex who don't know what
they're doing the truth about sex comes
in a white manila envelope Oh
one to two minutes was too short that
makes sense
adequate is three to seven minutes okay
like just some sweet splat and that's
how I like it done what that's barely
any different so we have like really
abnormally high expectations breathe
attack I was over but like that means
that we are getting adequate thick too
long is 10 mm okay well you know I was
creating a story in my head
ra it was romantic we were in love too
tight and it's is too long this is who
are they asking yeah
[Music]
average time five point minute so well
you know what yeah I can't argue with
that five point four minutes this is
fine it is fine everything I don't think
that there is any reason to be ashamed
of how long you last in bed I think as
long as you're communicating openly and
making sure that you're both getting
what you need then it's fine in sex
there's just so much anxiety and it
sucks and there's so much pressure
that's where the problem lies and
there's so much expectation there's no
need for worrying that should be about
enjoying each other's bodies and just
like having fun do some fun things that
extend the length of everything and then
the person probably won't even notice
that the literal like penetration -
coming for you was like only very short
based on a 2008 study in the Journal of
Sexual Medicine
if Journal of Sexual Medicine I need to
subscribe to that oh yeah
[Music]